you know this is the biggest film yet
all of auradon is in danger there's new
characters involved happening in this
movie it's game over the shots are just
epic in their big you know we're all
just like gone for it here it is here it
is descendants three is coming at this
summer and the cast gave et just enough
to hold us over till then at Disney
Channel Fan Fest at Disneyland is this
movie darker than the other two would
you say yeah I would say it's darker I
would say it's darker but it's more
grounded Tina I mean it's not like edgy
for the sake of edgy it's like actual
dark things
we're dealing with there is a villain
though there's several villains I don't
know maybe there's no villains maybe
we're the villains actually technically
we are the villains plot twist but you
guys are where we are yeah where are we
we have Hades Ryan Jackson who is
absolutely iconic uma is back and Sara
Jeffers character goes bad on us as well
so there's a lot happening a great evil
will have their revenge and all or dawn
forever there's a few epic battles but
there's one particular epic battle slash
dance-off that was so much fun I love
being able to incorporate dance music
acting as well as sword fighting like
that's such an incredible experience I
get to do his actors so that was really
cool and really epic she was three
helps my flowers slipping away I feel
like every movie mal grows at like an
exponential rate so this is her biggest
film yet everything that you want for
her happens I would say the way that
this story wraps up it's just everything
feels romantic and familial and warm and
like yeah I just can't wait for people
to see it I can't say too much I've had
the honor of my life telling Evy story
so in this third movie I wanted to make
sure that her story really came to a
beautiful conclusion and it really does
what's in store for Jay what descendants
three so much actually a lot but you get
to see him grow as a person
he's kind of all about just finding out
who you really are and not being not
hiding behind anything yeah which is
nice I know how villains day we are very
short on time my favorite of the three
films for sure is this the last one you
know this is the last installment in
this particular descendants chapter yeah
how was it onset knowing that I mean
were you guys emotional it was it
definitely heightens everything tied
into every single day for us every day
was goober emotional and just every
thing became more special because we
knew it was the end especially the last
few days for the four of us because you
know it all started with the four of us
and have changed our lives so the last
few days were really magical and
emotional you just kind of thought it
was I'm trying to say it was actually
very sad at the end like emotional mean
yeah yeah right there I think there's no
there's
he's handsome man
[Music]